in this capsule we will see
reinforcement learning
direct estimates so firstly
we'll do a little reminder of
process on marco well it's a
concept that will come back often in
learning does reinforcement then
a brand decision process comes back
it will be defined by a set
of states are they states
possible for our agenda
the environment a set of actions
that I noted actions of hesse where
sometimes two is so that gives
the set of possible actions for a
agent if he is in ace state
then have a transition model
who tells us if the money this hole to
help to the action stalled the
distribution of states in which it
could be after doing
the action therefore has for a next state
expresses what is its probability that this
the new state for my agency
was before in the state is what he has
does the action to see it also a
reward function that gives me the
reward associated with being in
the state is it finally the notion of
plan or policy so these are
synonyms i'm going to use them one or
the other so interchangeably so a
plan or policy worse if a whole
of decisions that associates with a state
is the action to which is taken by
my agent who follows this policy that
I note there is also a notion of
value is this for a data plane pi on
find here
so this value is given
as the sum of the rewards to
from now on to infinity
do it right so we take a nap the
value to a state s are being the
current reward plus a factor of this
gamma tale times the sum of
rewards future hope is what I
can do it's the crimes to write it
recurrently
that is, I can because the
values ​​correspond to the sum of
rewards from
until the end but I can say in fact
that rewards future hope it's
simply hope according to the
transition probability of my
environment for the action that I
take but you have the hope according to
its distribution the values ​​in
expresses so where the probability of passing
premium sas is used in my
experience here and so that's the
value for a given map so rather
that notes is saved from an ace by
against using v2 udder is this just for
make explicit the fact that this is the
value for a plan that gave and then
for those who also look in
books received the nordiques
instead we study u2 notation ud
so with one foot exposing him from
but it's both are just two
different ways of noting the notion of
the value of a plan to give something
we will add an apprenticeship
parents necessarily is the existence of
terminals in my environment
if these terminals get bored of states or if
the agent reaches the times question
was terminal the vote simulation is
stopped that is to say that there is no
other states or as in power
to achieve after that the experience of
money in the environment is going
just end and who will we
to interest in fact is the sum of
rewards but until we
reaches a terminal state rather than the
sum of rewards to infinity
then to tick toe bath and to
terminal it could be a grid of
game over
so once all the boxes in
leaflets were filled more
play spite of actions that are we
can then take in this case this is
the kind of state that would be who
would correspond terminal states in
this decision process on Wednesday
so let's start by defining liguria
passive reinforcement learning
and then from its edge to its destination
direct which is an example 1 4 and 5 of
Steam flu and learning
will necessarily speak easy
then very strong advantage even
passive that's it's going to solve the
next problem given a plan worse
given to take the value function
so the value of the plan worse without
know the transition model pds
get your chance and so you're
learning by necessarily at each
time we can not assume we know
the transition model
learning parents inevitably passive
it's a body where we know grandpa
of mind thus knowing to but we are
give a specific plan to follow and one
just want to know what's the value
exploit to illustrate giving
examples of learning without
necessarily pass the fund will use
this example tic is taken from the book of
russell and so would maginot we have
a grid 3 by four and in this
grid there in no we do not already specify a
plan that followed in the grid this there the
plan corresponds to the direction towards
which was aja would move in
following this plan for example here
the agent is moving towards
the top here agenzia by fee of
move by the left institute see
also a reinforcement function
which are going to be minus 0.04 by all
except at the terminal states that are here
so these are times if the agent
reached this state there simulation stops
experience the agent to the environment
and one can from their calculations
and the sum of the reinforcements and that that
is going to be actually the cumulative buildup
than
the agent got in his experience
in this environment and read and have
completed also a value of
reinforcement in this case it's going to be
more and so the agent will be like that and
means if the agent would it
the environment and stochastic so
in that if the agent wishes to pass
by then jean pardon is in this
state if and who wish to take
the action go up and a
certain probability that is going to be the most
so the most likely thing that
will happen is that the agent is going to
move to that state though but some
probability also which is to
seven folders instead so it's a
stochastic environment or the
result of my actions and not
fully determined and so this
people stop at the finished states on
terminals and we will use a
constant seconds that will be equal
so in the decision process
mark ovi we saw previously
when we talked about validation of their
studies
it's important to have a value of
factors of this bridge that was
strictly smaller than one otherwise
had problems because in the
definition of decision processes
easy to mac os well before we
did not have both terminals what what
with chords of smaller seconds
because we could culin
reward a movie when also because
we have completed stages we can
allow to have a factor of this tale
which is equal to 1 so it turns out that
in this case if the notion of value
of a plan so the sum of rewards
hope is going to be something that goes that
should normally converge so that's
something we can afford
here for this dish
so because we do not know our
transition model
everything we can do and
learn from simulations
these simulations the man call them some
English tests giles so that's it
is the money that starts at a
given state because if we are going to assume
that the initial state is always the
box 1 1
and in that if we have an example of
3.30 from three trials where money in
following the actions specified by our
policy and started at the state 1.1 to
that time got a reward from
- 0 point 0 4 and then of this in
following the action of the policy in
question this one conducted to test himself
the at the state 1 2 which in reward
partner of minus 0.04 to those already at
the state 1 2 of tracking the action given by
politics and that brought him to
the hall and gold 1 3 who has a reward
from - 0 point 0 k so on until
what he eventually reaches a state
final a 4-point terminal state and captured
3 the fund 4.3 is one of the states of
terminale seller terminal associate
an extra reward in mexico at
third try we had a simulation
who led us to a different state for
the second
after taking the first action so
from 1.1 to myself taking the same action as
the action that was taken here because we
always follows the same politics we
has been given
the agent ended up in the state earlier
2 1
because it's an environment that
stochastic so there was a
protein which he two years after the
same action of happened to state two
hours earlier than the condition 1,2 and dense
that if the simulation bring him rather to
the terminal state 4.2 in box 4 2 and that
that gave him in this case also for
this one
reinforcement of -1 and there the problem of
learning parents inevitably
pacifies 6 and esteem of them to have a
estimate of value
in any case is this for this policy
designed it first approach we're going
see it's the one of direct estimation
and senna pages that is super simple everything
what are we going to do his calculations and the
average of what is observed in the
tests to calculate estimate value
vds for the designed plan so I repeat if
the tests so the three simulations of
our agent who followed the policy
then given when you want city but
what would be the value for our
policy followed in state 1.1
we observe, among other things, that
a hockey who visited state 1.1 but
the sum of the rewards from 1 1
to a terminal state it was less
0.04 plus points - point 04 - points 0.4
at 1.048 months after 0.4
the smo 1.04 let me 1.04 +1 function
to sum up all that in fact we have
a reward of 0.72 so what we
observe is that to leave one
the sum of future rewards was to
from state 1.1
in fact the sum of the rewards to a
the future rewards was 0.72
in the sky two from 1 1
we observe again 0.62 are there
so many states with a reward
negative of - 0 point 0 4 then
finally the same and terminal with a
reward no longer just that we have the
same reward sum of rewards
up to a terminal of 0.72 on trial
three years something different
we have a test that has been a little less
long then finally we had a
negative reward at the end of which
gives a sum of the rewards of -1
point and direct estimate 10 10
to estimate the value
go outside
just average what has
was observed stasi the average of 0.72
0.72 - 1.16 and when if that gives us
ride 0.10 0933 3 another example of
the direct estimate when it's for
state 1 2 part is observed in the test
1 that the condition 1,2 visited twice and
so the first time here is the
second time it's here then for the
first time they visit and the
sum of the rewards of this state there
until the end from this pass to here
it's going to be a two three four five
six times less points 0.4 +1 which we
gives a total sum of 0.65 for
stick here we have one two three four
times less points 0.4 of rewards
plus + 1 which would give confidence
total slightly higher by 0.84 in
the east it's hard we visit the state 1,2 here
and as in the series we get a
sum of the rewards of 0.76 then the c3
do not visit state 1 2 so in that
if we do not learn anything from the
value at 1.2 for the 6 3 so in this
that if the direct estimate what that
would give us so simply the average
of 0.76 0.84 and 0.76 which gives us
an estimated value of 0.78 is therefore
it's simply the procedure for
get a direct estimate of the
value of a body of water is so it's
parenting precision
necessarily passive based on the estimate
direct